kinderschänder ring in vier
bundesländern einmal nrw hessen
niedersachsen und brandenburg
unser bild reporter til biermann
recherchierte vor allem in brandenburg
in finowfurt zu einem täter enrico l t
was konntest du denn über den täter
enrico herausfinden
ja der in riga erscheint ein sehr
fleißiger mann zu sein der arbeitet im
schichtdienst veränderst läge es immer
gemeinsam mit seiner frau er war
außerdem noch vorsitzender eines
gartenvereins sachen wir gerade die paar
bilder gesehen von seinem garten verein
unterhalb von ich glaube insgesamt
sieben staaten hatte auch sie zu tun und
das macht sorgen er war auch karate
trainer und zwar in einem verein der so
wie es aussieht hauptsächlich
jugendliche und kinder trainierte im
zusammenhang mit den taten ist das dann
schon besorgniserregend
erzähl du konntest auch mit
verschiedenen leuten sprechen was hat
dann zum beispiel die nachbarschaft zu
dem fall gesagt die nachbarn vor allen
dingen bei dem kleingartenverein wo es
schon seit langem ist können sich dass
alle gar nicht vorstellen da sagte dass
es wäre ja vielleicht einen doppelgänger
also das ist halt diese typische
geschichte was man ja auch öfter mal
gehört dass keiner sich vorstellen kann
dass er solche taten begangen haben
könnte was auffällt das sehen wir jetzt
ihr im video
rechts ist die alte baracke dass so ein
also holz bereits seit längerem baute
daneben ein massives beton haus mit
einem schmieden eisentür im zusammenhang
mit den taten in münster wäre dann
natürlich auch zu überlegen was er davor
gehabt haben könnte in diesem beton aus
man sieht hier auch schaukeln vor dem
haus und es ist ja auch klar dass adrian
v ihn zumindest dort mal besucht hat
denn sein auto wurde in der regierung
gesehen